welcome everybody we are here once again
awaiting today's White House coronavirus
press briefing originally scheduled for
five pm has been rescheduled for 5:30
p.m. already that's why I started a
little bit later anticipating that this
would happen as it does every day
meaning we are about a half hour away
yesterday I believe yesterday was the
latest Trump has been since the start of
these he started an hour and 12 minutes
late if I recall correctly yesterday
originally scheduled for five p.m.
Eastern started at 6:12 p.m. Eastern do
I do I have that right I guess I'd have
to go back and look exactly but not good
and very disrespectful very very
disrespectful expecting so what do we
have on tap this week monday was
propaganda day Trump played a five
minute propaganda video in the press
briefing room may be illegal in terms of
a campaign finance from the standpoint
of a campaign finance violation
yesterday was all about naming companies
and actually I have something really
good for you guys let me see I actually
just remembered that I had it and now I
don't know where to find it let's see
video format where was this thing oh
here it is okay check this out Kareem
made this for me yesterday it was
exactly as I described check this out
this is really good Trump naming all of
his company friends yesterday now we
have a list of people that I'll be
speaking to over the next very short
period of time in many cases tomorrow
the American Farm Bureau Federation
Cisco Systems Tyson Foods Perdue farms
gargle Archer Daniels Midland company
Pratibha Tractor Supply Company sequent
operation bring me farms matter farms
Bank of America JP Morgan Chase gonna
sexy group else are going to a banquet
for consumer rapid sigmax on the back
will be a workhorse initially engineers
building trade unions do a lot of
friends and my Labor's international
associations associations or contractors
associated general contractor's varmint
walkie button Honeywell filter broman
with UN General Dynamics
Sequoyah McDonald's subway United
Airlines general by Gen rush anthem
United Health Group at the Cigna and
Humana we have Tim Apple Google sundar
that was an unfair cut he didn't really
say Tim Apple but I loved it I loved it
anyway
ok that was yesterday ok so yesterday
was just like huge huge naming of
companies essentially and I will I will
post that as a standalone clip at some
point soon so today we are expecting one
one or two of the following two things
number one
Trump's council to reopen America is he
going to present it today
earlier in the week reported by Fox News
that Jared and Ivanka who Trump if uncle
wasn't Trump's daughter he would date
her right remember that's the one I'm
talking about they were supposedly on
the council then Trump said they're not
on the council
we're waiting to hear who's on the
council and then secondly Trump is going
to present a plan to reopen states some
states even earlier than May first he
said it seems like we're not at all
ready for that it seems like that would
be a very bad decision but that maybe
today that may come tomorrow it may come
Friday we don't really know so if you're
just joining me those are the things we
are waiting for now a little personal
aside in the midst of everything going
on with coronavirus everything going on
with you know we've decentralized all of
our work you know all this different
stuff last night I go to fill my Brita
pitcher at about 10:15 p.m. and the
water comes out Brown that we the citrus
the the plumbing browned out yesterday
for lack of a better term if I may and
not good and it stunk Brown stinky
water is not what you want coming out of
your faucet so you know it's 10:15 I
call the Boston Water and Sewer
Commission they pick up it's screaming
it sounds like there's a murderer go
it's chaos at the Boston Water and Sewer
Commission a guy tells me boil it if
you're going to drink it
showering is fine but then my neighbor
called and they told the neighbor down
the street don't even shower with this
stuff we don't know what's going on a
water main broke but it has nothing to
do with the water main we're flushing
this but it insane so I ended up having
to boil water and I had ice balls like
you know those big Ice Cube like you're
gonna get a big round ice ball for like
a lowball glass I had four big ice balls
in my freezer and I put them in with the
boiled water to make like lukewarm water
that I could then brush my teeth with so
that was in the middle of everything we
had a brownout from the watering system
and just terrible terrible terrible and
this morning it was all basically
resolved I just ran the water this
morning for a little bit throughout all
my ice obviously from my fridge we're
starting fresh I don't break can you
imagine brown ice insane so that was
yesterday so now we're back to you know
hopefully normality today as far as the
water goes but we've got plenty of
nuclear weapons in case anybody are you
mad that we have no shortage of
whatsoever but the water browning out it
is what it is okay a few super chats
then I have clips to play for you Rachel
Vander Linda subscribed on YouTube Carol
Strickland's sons a super chat John
Hubbard has subscribed zesty African
says should progressives gain leverage
by not voting or should we give in to
the tendencies of a person similar to
Stockholm Syndrome false dichotomy many
videos on my youtube channel about it
already
inconsolable says look like the
protesting is heating up and getting
crazy in Michigan I have videos for you
I have videos for you do you think it'll
be reflected in the general or just a
vocal minority I don't know but I've got
clips Paul JM says David can you
announce the new patreon Zinn the same
way trust Trump listed the name of the
CEOs last night loved the show
I will try to do that today okay so we
have a goal of 25 patrons today I will
try to announce them in the way that
Trump yesterday was was announcing his
friends for his CEO friends thanks to
Paula frost for the super chapped David
Adams says WWE paid the Florida
government to be essential well Vince
McMahon runs some kind of pro Trump PAC
or something right so you know you could
figure out the financial connection
there
Seth Barham says David has your alcohol
consumption increased since doing these
regularly my alcohol consumption is
essentially down to zero
during quarantine I I don't I don't
smoke and we know that smoking is not
good if you catch kovat 19 and it's
unclear about drinking and it's not like
I'm so into drinking I essentially I
think I've had one beer in the last
month
honestly I'm almost just like too busy
to even sit down and have a beer but I
have not my drinking is down very very
much down Richard testa filt that's the
flit says got my mom and stepdad to
watch today hi mom oh hi to Richard's
mom and stepdad you're beautiful unknown
prodigy says I got my mom to watch today
to go David
all right missus prodigy welcome and
amplitude has upgraded their membership
on YouTube okay let's get right to some
videos somebody mentioned Michigan there
let me find okay so here's what's going
on in Michigan check this out these are
two furious judging by their physical
age at risk individuals who are
desperate desperate to get things
reopened and they're mad and they're
protesting mass rallying in a state with
a ton of cases and very little testing
Michigan I can't go between those houses
you can't buy paint you can't fight a
law you can't be a lawn fertilizer or
grass seed or whatever come on all
statewide really you know it's time for
seat to be opened up we're tired of not
being able to buy the things that we
need go to the hairdresser's get her
hair done yeah if this guy is this
desperate for manure he should just
watch the press briefings with me and
and by the way I Amazon will ship you
fertilizer it'll take a little bit but
it'll ship it to you I looked it up
hardware stores are reportedly open in
Michigan they'll bring the stuff out
directly to your car you got to call
your credit card in ahead of time it's
not only insane what this guy is saying
and doing it's also inaccurate right
because you can get for it but I've
never been this shaken up about lawn
fertilizer by the way you should see
what I have going on in my lawn it's a
[ __ ] show I should be crying about lawn
fertilizer but I'm not this guy is he
can get it so that's what's going on in
Michigan and it is very very toxic
here's the other one
okay so we got that got that out of the
way very very good I'll get back to that
later
okay here's Kelly Ann Conway now this is
gonna start as a goof but it's gonna get
me into something serious so please bear
with me as you know kovat 19 is the
virus caused by Tsarskoe v2 Kellyanne
Conway here refers to Co vat19 as if
it's corona virus number 19 like we've
had 1 through 18 and this is corona
virus number 19 so clearly the w-h-o
should have been more prepared they had
18 co beds to prepare the president took
decisive and immediate action the end of
January to shut down flights from China
that was criticized by the whu-oh it was
criticized by other people as an Olympic
and racist and travel bans don't work
well this one sure did
so we have every right to know and every
right to know because of what's happened
here in this global pandemic but there's
another reason some of the scientists
and doctors say that there could be
other strains later on this could come
back in the fall in a limited way this
is Kovan 19 not Cova duan folks say this
sheds a whole new light onto the movie
k-9 cop right I was always wondering
what happened to 1 through 8 my mom
didn't know because we're from Argentina
she wasn't familiar with the series this
now explains to me what is going on now
of course this is crazy kovat 19 means
coronavirus from the year
but this does relate to something
serious okay there's a lot we don't know
so I'm not presenting to you this to you
as something I know but it's something
I've been reading about we have all
these eight asymptomatic positive tests
for coronavirus but there's a really
important thing to remember you've got
Tsarskoe v2 which is the virus and
you've got kovat 19 which is the illness
caused by the virus the tests that we
have right now in a hospital tests for
the press the presence of the virus not
for the illness there's not a test for
the illness so there's the idea this is
just an idea that some of these
asymptomatic cases test you're right the
thing goes in you test positive for
Tsarskoe v2 but you've got no symptoms
you may just not have kovat 19 ok so
again I'm gonna say this in a different
way just because the virus is in your
body does not guarantee it has infected
you and that you have a case of kovat 19
it's speculative it's an idea there's so
much we don't know that we're learning
that could be an explanation it may not
be that all these positive tests are
asymptomatic cases of kovat 19 they
could be merely the presence of Tsarskoe
v2 the virus that is in the body but has
failed to infect the person am I being
clear about that I I don't want to be
confusing to people okay it's not clear
if I'm confusing people or not but if I
did confuse people
then I sincerely apologize alright that
is that I'll get back to this in a
little bit okay we're still standing by
for live video here okay let's see other
super chats nasty questions says David
your streams are awesome Thanks thank
you foolish says David can I get a shout
out to my wife Leah a nurse working for
her 18th straight night today on the New
York City crisis thanks for the stream
also Leah thank you we so appreciate the
work you were doing and all other health
care workers you are putting yourselves
at risk we
working to get a an emergency use
vaccine for healthcare workers as soon
as possible the lead nih person working
on the corona virus vaccine was on
anderson cooper's show last night and
explained they are hoping to have that
available for healthcare workers in
mid-october and thank you so much for
your great work leah mica gelfand says
thanks for keeping it real with us David
I appreciate the show Massachusetts
native and fellow tribe member yes a
belated hug Sameach to mica Gelfand I
could tell you some stories about the
last name gelfand but they would not be
appropriate for they wouldn't be
appropriate for this stream that's for
sure Henry Vinson sends a super chat
Daniel Krieger says crystal informally
invited you onto rising today to discuss
whether to vote Biden she seems to
disagree with you would be fascinating
to see she's got my number she can
invite me anytime
Casey Matthew says your hair is too neat
today please mess it up too so it
reflects how we feel yeah I apologize I
went running today but there's been a
total lack of wind so my hair stayed
moderately under control
Debbie hallström subscribes on YouTube
MW says the David Pakman show is my
guilty pleasure oh boy Jamal Swift says
hey homie conspiracy theories
correlating coronavirus aside do you
have any info about 5-g being unhealthy
to the general health no I have info
about it not being unhealthy that's the
only info I have David Pakman says my
uncle said coronavirus is hoax like
Russia collusion he said Dems will do
anything to destroy Trump and they hate
America thoughts that's what's called
weaponized ignorant Dennis says
Smithfield cluster Sioux Falls South
Dakota gov says all okay all right
aurilla podge says David I've got
friends saying China's holding back
virus research and are calling for
punishment sanctions on the country is
this true and shouldn't we be trying to
cooperate with them well you know we can
simultaneously say China does some bad
things but we're better off mostly
cooperating with them on this particular
issue right like both can be true
at the same time if you're watching on
Twitter twitch YouTube or Facebook which
should be all of you we're standing by
for today's White House coronavirus
press briefing scheduled for 5:30 p.m.
Eastern Time just about 15-20 minutes
from now we may hear from Donald Trump
today the plan to start reopening some
states which states those would be we
don't know the official global count is
now over two million coronavirus cases
and a hundred and thirty-four thousand
deaths now unfortunately the numbers
have worsened dramatically here in the
United States it looked like we were
over the peak things started to level
out things also started to level out in
terms of deaths and even decline and
then yesterday we had 2,400 deaths the
high we already have 23 36 today with
still many hours to go we will likely
set another new death record today so if
you think we're anywhere close to
needing to open things up you are very
very wrong and what Donald Trump is
likely to talk about today if he talks
about reopening States likely to be very
very dangerous the health data org ih
Emmy model has still not been updated
since April 13th but this is a model
that increasingly is of questionable
accuracy and there have been a number
now of serious questions about its
accuracy including state-level data so
at this point I don't know what's going
on and I don't know how long we are
going to have to wait until we really
know when we are past the peak but it's
not clear we're even past it at this
point very sad very very sad to say
David Pakman Germany branch officer
where did that go branch office had
court David
I can only say all Americans should take
a look at the corona crisis management
of the German government no comparison
almost every country I mean okay Brazil
hasn't necessarily handled it better
it's not clear that Iran has handled it
better almost every country has had a
better response tactical cupcakes says
have you seen the film idiocracy feels
like we're living in it right now
love the show thanks for being an
intelligence buffer for these briefings
I have seen idiocracy yeah David Pakman
says thoughts on Russia collusion
one-year anniversary no thoughts dealing
with the virus
bob'll oblong says White House keeps
play propaganda at the briefing for
cheeto bonitos re-election couldn't say
it better myself
Zachary Pro Kowski says not to give
Conway too much credit but while this
isn't the 19th coronavirus it is the
second one this whole thing is SARS -
SARS goes global No
yeah there's no doubt that this is not
the first we've ever heard of a corona
virus but corona virus virus 19 as the
19th coronavirus epidemic or pandemic is
cuckoo for cocoa puffs absolutely crazy
okay let's now review this I showed this
to people yesterday and there was great
interest in it there was a lot of
interest in it so I'm gonna show it
again this is a possible road map I
believe from Morgan Stanley it's from
one of the financial firms and say what
you want about them they have been
putting some pretty good roadmaps
together involving both medical and
public health and financial experts they
are putting out a road map that would
include a peak on the coasts and the
epicenters right around now and a peak
in the rest of the US probably in about
10 days
they are looking at increasing testing
capacity to 500,000 tests a day by the
end of April and a million tests a day
by the end of May they are counting on
an antibody test being widely available
in mid-june and then if we do all that
these are every single one of these is
an if they're looking at early infected
people people who were infected in
February March you know April people who
have recovered going back to work in
mid-june given that they will be able to
have antibody tests and will know if
they have the antibodies followed by
wave to returning to work in mid summer
even with this paradigm
the anticipation is that there will be a
second wave hopefully smaller but we
don't know in a November starting in
mid-november and with a potential
vaccine for healthcare workers in
mid-october and a potential vaccine more
broadly available somewhere around March
15 2021 every one of these elements is
speculative we don't know it's a road
map we there's a great interview on
Anderson Cooper show last night from the
lead NIH coronavirus vaccine researcher
she said if things go well there will be
an emergency use healthcare worker
vaccine available right where this says
mid-october so that this is not
delusional it just may not happen okay
this is a very good road map it seems
moderately realistic you know Trump's
talking about open up twenty states in
total in ten days that seems like a
death wish but okay that that's what
Donald Trump seems seems committed to be
doing okay one other thing and then I'm
gonna get back to super chats and and
other things diamond and silk these are
two delusional supporters of Donald
Trump they now say they will refuse a
vaccine for the virus that Bill Gates is
involved in and check out the other
crazy things they say yes we don't need
to look at the communal ride what
happened Africa trying to vaccinate they
felt like stuff can start right there in
certain parts of that's what we don't
need to do not go make black people not
the guinea pig for this we're not gonna
be your experience or your project ask
pyramid that's we asked pyramid that's
strange
not black yes today bill yes the surgeon
the Surgeon General was talking to as a
matter of fact he was treated today
listen I tell us what we need to know
yeah but I always look at the underbelly
of what's going on in treating me yeah
that's my intuitive yeah counterpart yes
uh-huh
what are you about to do here right
because what you not gonna do you
start vaccinating blackphone right we
have a vaccination card just to go
together you're not gonna do that and
what it does it it'll start with us
first does anybody know if these women
are sisters
lovers friends look who I just don't
really understand the show see they got
us with slavery they got us with Jim
Crow not about the push this here mass
vaccination and listen
kudos if you make your vaccines for
people and you want to help you mmm-hmm
but I have a problem receiving any
vaccine from any entity especially
anybody like Bill Gates he pushed for
population control so anyway these
conspiracies I have people I went to
high school with who I've I've I've
muted them on Facebook I've unfollowed
them on Facebook who have been pushing
the Bill Gates conspiracy theories and
it's it's sick it's absolutely just sick
vile and completely disgusting III don't
know how else I can even describe it
okay Safra geum says i'm confused one
can have the virus while the viral will
the viral load determine the infection
and how the heck has it tested if it can
be tested these are all questions that
we still need to answer
Sabrina safar says let your hair grow
out to the length and style of Donald
Trump and then bleach it channel will
explode you know what I would consider
doing that I would I'm not super
interested in shaving my head because it
might grow back in weird but I would
consider letting it go and then
bleaching it to Trump's hair color if we
got to I said 4,000 patrons and maybe
that's the right number I don't mean
like that that's a lot to do and I think
it's pretty bad for your hair to bleach
it but I would consider doing something
like that I would certainly consider
doing something like that David Collins
Key says does Joe Biden have cognitive
decline if so why do you keep avoiding
the issue I'm not avoiding the issue I
think there's no doubt that Joe Biden is
slowed down from where he was ten years
ago but every mental health expert that
I've spoken to again I don't prevent
pretend to know anything myself about
this I just go to the experts
every mental health expert I've asked
about this says to me in their opinion
what's going on with Biden is not what
is going on with Trump I am NOT a mental
health professional so I wouldn't come
up with my own ideas about this I can
only tell you what experts are saying
Frank when Ruiz says what keeps
Americans from rising up against the
danger of a president and protest in
Washington love your show a Dutch fan
check out my videos about how the system
is designed to prevent really effective
protests I've got a bunch of videos
about that on my youtube channel thanks
to Mary Allen who says oh wait a second
where did that go Mary Allen sends a
super chat and Zook sends one Tony a
Tommy Galvez says hello from Washington
you soy boy and big fan thanks Tommy
Atari DC are my trump bucks worth more
than itchy and scratchy bucks
let's hope so Charlie says David at what
point does your hair become a safety
issue PS destroy that like button yes if
you're watching on YouTube we've had
almost 20,000 people come through the
stream and only 600 likes please smash
that like button and do the full oh I
just knocked over
oh god my water just went flying I'm
gonna have to clean that up maybe hold
on a second I'm gonna have to mop that
up with a piece of paper and legal pads
don't absorb much I'm actually just
sorry about that you have no idea what I
just did here anyway
smash the like button I'm not going to
fully wind up there and hit the
subscribe button as well both they're
both are appreciated my hair is soon
going to be a safety issue in fact there
are certain southern states where it
would already not be allowed Oh looks
like we think some things are moving we
are getting closer to the start of
today's press briefing scheduled for the
bottom of the hour waiting for the event
to begin okay does anybody know if we
have any stream that is live in the room
I would love to see what's happening in
the room the White House stream is not
live in the room the yeah I'm just not
seeing anybody live in the room right
now but we will soon see okay
Ms Smith says what are your thoughts on
the UK response to this I'm not an
expert in the UK response so I'm not
really the right person to comment on it
Connor Brenner says interesting Putin is
now talking reality ANCOVA
yeah there's been a big change Dennis
says look up Smithfield Foods South
Dakota largest cluster I will Linda
Plaza says please keep your crazy hair
it makes these streams bearable ok I'm
going to a try to announce new patrons
now in the way that Donald Trump listed
companies during yesterday's stream I
want to say thanks to some friends of
mine
Tyler dang Mary Steve parmi Phil Swanson
Phil Phil's a great guy Phil Phil
Swanson they are new patrons 1 2 3 & 4
today at patreon.com slash David Pakman
I'll mention this one time and soon
things are getting started I would very
much appreciate if you are able to
support the stream and the clips and the
podcast and the work that we do consider
making the teeny tiny eeny weeny little
pledge of $1 a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we currently
have let me refresh here 1853 patrons I
think it would be beautiful if we could
crest 2,000 during today's stream but
the goal is just 25 okay
so consider that I know that a lot of
folks are strapped for cash I don't want
your money the streams are for everybody
we're here every single day doing the
thing but consider making a pledge we
had a pledge of $100 a month yesterday
but I don't need you to do that you can
go as low as one dollar a month one
dollar a month
add a patreon.com slash david pakman
show and I will thank everybody all
these beautiful little pledges of
absolutely fantastic okay Timothy says
exit live chat and smash the like button
everyone also than you David okay Mary
Allen says I feel empowered to push back
on trumpets after watching him through
your show shout out to Governor Hogan
and his team he gave the ASL interpreter
a citation today like a like a speeding
ticket a citation today during his press
briefing Oh like the good kind of
citation I got it
Ricky Williams oh boy even fewer people
here today Ricky Williams the fact that
they brought tea by the way the fact
that they brought TVs outside is not a
good sign if you believe in logic reason
and truth my prediction is that's not
good for us
Ricky Williams says Republicans you
can't demand another person's labor also
Republicans we demand the country open
now the party of walking contradictions
very much so
let me say thank you to some very very
special twitch goers doctor sprite 13
has subscribed with twitch prime the
Mike Lennon has done the same and says
keep up the good reporting David C n IJ
Pels has subscribed with prime and
Christy Mack has also subscribed on
YouTube so has its ya boy D Z who has
subscribed with twitch prime as well
brilliant brilliant okay let me do some
more Trump style thank yous for people
signing up on patreon got some very
special people that I want to thank
today these are people these are great
people these are great people these are
my friends these are a lot a lot of
these people and they love it they love
what we've been doing from the
standpoint of co vid 19 as they call it
kai Shona Weiss Townsend Kok Rob
Contreras Sarah Holly Sarah Bastian
Dennis char Doug Saylor
okay how many is that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ok
so that gets us to 12 patrons 12 patrons
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
ok other super chats continuing to come
in
sean teatro says do you think the model
inaccuracies are due to the strange
rollout and in
assistant testing partially or was that
built into the models I know you're not
a model or just curious about your
opinion the primate there's two things
going on with models number one modeling
infectious disease is difficult number
two knowing about the model influences
people's behavior which changes the
model rinse repeat ad infinitum as the
kids these days say so there's a number
of important things to consider there
Dian Mars Oney says hey David loved the
show I'm super happy I got my stimulus
check without Trump's signature /name
yeah normal policy oh says as a
hairstylist your hair is stressing me
out
it's fine guy I mean listen this is so
low on my list of priorities right now
it's fine David Pakman says kolinsky
tweeted to you trump better on TPP and
North Korea perhaps even first step but
overall I view them both beyond the pale
what are your thoughts I think Joe
Biden's clearly orders of magnitude
better than Trump and I'll be voting for
him because we can't have Trump picking
the next Supreme Court justice we just
can't a gape ascention grabs a youtube
subscription base the dragon asks
thoughts on the money for the people
bill being brought to the house I've
bookmarked it to look at I don't have
the full details yet
Noah Camacho says would you debate Kyle
on Biden could help undecided voters you
know I'm not sure because I don't want
to divide the left at all and me
debating Kyle where our audiences have a
lot of overlap it could do more damage
than it does good so I want to be really
careful I don't want to take any action
that could divide the left because I
think that that's really a bad thing
EB Pryor says do you wear any kind of
mask when and if you go out I haven't so
far because I don't have one but let me
see as many of you know I'm filming from
home now and I have my my my stuff here
my winter I guess I could use a scarf
and I guess I'd have to tie it up when
we see if this is even possible
okay I guess I need to be able to see
let me see hold on I guess I could go
out like this something like this right
I'd have to Ono I think my face anyway I
think I'd have to use a scarf I don't
think I really have any other options
because I don't I just don't have any
masks I've not been able to get them and
I just don't know how you're supposed to
tie it I guess like this yeah but I have
not yet gone out with a mask there are
some grocery stores though that are
going to be enforcing mandatory masks
very soon and they're looking at that
very strongly so I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna have to start and it's just been
because I haven't had one that's really
it okay let me do a few other um thank
yous for patrons and I'm gonna try the
to do them oh I thought I'd lost my
earpiece there trying that on I'm gonna
try to do them like trumps thank yous
yesterday remember this is a Microsoft
Facebook welcome so in da baseball's EPG
LPGA okay anyway I think you guys get
the idea okay so new patrons today very
special patrons people I want to thank I
want to thank Claudio and Melissa Wayman
Kai wilcoxon Wolfie Samuel Schwimmer
Jamie Lilienfeld Janet Robinson Jessica
Deaton kela Bolin Elizabeth Schmitt
Matson Rob screw wire I have to also
pretend to not understand some of the
names which is a big thing that Trump
does that's 11 more that gets us to 23
patrons today 23 pages oh and you know
what team Aiken has quintupled their
pledge from two to ten dollars so I'm
gonna count that as new patron number 24
just to be polite I feel like this is a
time of trying to come together and all
of that stuff let me say thanks to one
of the Smurfs for the twitch
subscription one of the Smurfs says
don't know how you're able to do this
every day good question snowy 9m
subscribes with prime spoo
he says ye never lose with their
subscription alpha buds says hey David
do you think the WH o hid things going
on in China it's possible I don't
pretend to know I don't pretend to know
okay Donna Williams says diamond and
xilk and silk are really zirconia and
polyester disgusting good job David as
always AC Krause says just listen to
Christian droste in if you need
information on the virus he's the expert
on viruses and is on Twitter at C
underscored Rosten greetings from
Germany I will check that out I'm not
familiar with with him okay where did
that go where was I oh boy here we go
Mike says I'm in Michigan I know a few
who were protesting a lot in the trades
unfortunately Oh a n maybe the choice
news of a lot of protesters lots of
Republicans blame Whitmer's actions
instead of Trump's inaction yeah just
totally misplaced blame it's it's really
sad townsend coke says predictions on
college is opening high school senior i
I really don't know I'm already hearing
from friends who teach at colleges that
they may be doing the fall online which
would mean colleges will be open but
just not in person I don't know you know
if you put a gun to my head and say
you've got a bet is in person college
starting in September or not until
January February I might go with January
February to be perfectly frank I I mean
it's it's bad it's really the numbers
are really bad graph zero says
frustrating thing about testing they
tell you a negative test does not mean
you don't have it found that out
yesterday sick for almost three weeks
squarely says from Sweden after Bernie's
latest interview saying it's ridiculous
not to support Biden his word was
irresponsible have you seen a decline in
Bernie or Buster's no so far they've
been furious they've been very very
angry beetle Greg says hey David who's
your favorite wrestler I couldn't I
don't have I've never watched
professional wrestling armando Arriba
says please do a video debunking these
insaints conspiracy theories about kovat
too much disinformation going on stew
guy says worse fowey he wasn't there
yesterday was he I believe foul she was
not there yesterday and we will see if
he is here today
okay a few other patrons to thank I'm
gonna do them kind of the normal way now
new patron I'm number 25 today is Olga
Martinez new patron number 25 let's go
for fifty Tracy C is new patron number
twenty-six today and Steven Dubinski is
new patron number twenty-seven at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
thank you so much I really appreciate
your support and remember we are here
just about every day around the same
time taking your questions seeing what
sort of propaganda disinformation
delusions come from the press briefings
sometimes with a little bit of sense
from a doctor or two if you are watching
on YouTube please consider consider
pressing the like button and pressing
the subscribe button both are very
useful to us I had a beautiful perfect
phone call recently with my youtube rep
he was very excited about the rate of
subscription growth on YouTube we have
been we rocketed past eight hundred and
twenty three thousand 8 24 8 25 we're at
eight hundred and twenty six thousand
subscribers maybe eight twenty seven
within a day or two so I have only you
you all y'all you guys to thank for that
really really appreciate it Liz Francis
says hey from Michigan big fan thanks
for doing the show you're the only voice
of reason I'm not the only but I
appreciate the sentiment
Lynnae rhymer sends a super chat zachary
Foster says foul she did say small
events and sports are possible in may
without fans in a week-long interview
what are your thoughts on this yeah I
think it's possible I think it's
possible mark Kemp subscribes boiled
frog Cobb feffy
sends a super chat a Fazil Vanda says
david you should go for Liberty spikes
is that like a spiked mohawk or of some
kind I don't know that I know what that
is
Jeri Robeson says hey David loved the
show and your insights to this disaster
how about pushing pausing the c-span
stream when you want a fact check
spacebar will pause it you know the
thing about that is if I do that a bunch
of times will fall so far behind on the
stream people will get upset a lot of
people want to be watching live so you
know there's different views on that and
I've got to be very very careful with
that
Ben Taylor says yeah I think
impersonations are so fun Kyle K's Ben
Shapiro is the best Cheyne Simpson says
I'm currently a subscribed member but
would like to contribute more is patreon
preferable or would site memberships put
more money in the coffers well if you're
already a member
certainly mm-hmm go ahead and make a
pledge on patreon the thing about
patreon is there's a little bit of a
viral contagion effect where people see
oh eight hundred and fifty three people
have already pledged well then a whole
bunch more do it now 1876 people have
pledged that gets people excited about
can we get to 1900 can we get you get it
yeah I don't have to explain the
Internet to you guys so that's why a
patreon is very exciting and on that
note a few other thank-yous I want to
say thanks to IVA Gelf
Eva feller has more than doubled her
pledge and she's number 28 Rebecca Cowen
is new member number 29 today go wrong
Catan is number 30 today
Denis long is number 31 Marco Fabri is
number 32
Michael Blanco is number 33 David Laury
is number 34 and joy Avery
joy thank you you are new patron number
35 today today's press briefing was
originally scheduled for 5:00 p.m. that
was 38 minutes ago it was rescheduled to
5:30 and we are out now
eight minutes past that so
you know your guess is as good as mine
yesterday I think was the latest it's
ever started it was scheduled for five
and it ultimately started at 6:12 p.m.
Eastern Time which is crazy crazy crazy
crazy let me say thank you to amends or
for subscribing with twitch Prime rapid
Thor has subscribed with Prime jo-lynn
that's hard to pronounce has subscribed
with Prime I geuss 20 action WD u silane
way neo and sleep mode have all
subscribed with Prime and I very much
appreciate that Thomas Powell says sales
of toilet rolls to self isolate 7 I
don't even know what that means
sales of toilet rolls to sell isolate 7
I don't get that I don't know essential
says do you think Florida's numbers are
accurate well so here's the thing about
Florida let's pull that up so Florida
claims to have 22,000 cases 596 deaths
on the basis of 10,000 tests per million
people I don't think they're
particularly inaccurate although I would
wonder with Florida has the I believe
it's the fifth oldest population median
age population in the country I would
wonder if there are older folks in
Florida that are dying from the virus
but are never getting tested and
potentially not showing up in the death
numbers I'm just not sure satirical
Symphony says did you see the public
protest crowd in Michigan today yeah we
played some clips of it earlier
including some of the protesters Connor
Brenner says unfortunately David I think
it's only going to get worse imagine
what these misinformation campaigns will
be like in 10 years with deep fake
technology attack if we remain this
as a nation I'm as worried as you are my
friend Kayne Vinson says are you
expecting more bailouts or stimulus
checks in the future I am leaning that
way because it seems that Oh get it
getting a chair out of the way there it
seems this is going to go for a while it
seems this is going to go for quite some
time Pat O'Brien says no way oh it's
that love the streams long live the
vivid edge and Inter skate yeah Pat
O'Brien I've known Pat O'Brien for wait
how old my I think I've known Pat
O'Brien for 20 years I hope you're well
Pat I hope your family is doing well and
great great to see your face and name
pop up here Jeremiah 500 if Katelyn
Collins is leaving that suggests it's
gonna be a while unless it's just
getting chilly if she walks away we're
in for something very very bad here
uh-oh please sit back down
Oh is she leaving she's sitting back
down okay I was about to get very
worried Jeremiah 593 says hey David how
do you intervene with friends who are
going deeper down the conspiracy rabbit
hole without making them more defensive
and entrenched I don't really have any
close friends that are down the rabbit
hole so it just doesn't really come up
sometimes I'll see somebody like I went
to high school with on Facebook post
some cringe conspiracy stuff and I will
typically ignore it
I'll get an involved once in a while but
I don't have any close friends who
believe that stuff at least not that
they tell me if they believe it they're
keeping it quiet maybe because they know
I would not take kindly to it okay let
me say thank you to some new patrons our
deke Anna Dee is new patron number 36
today Diane marzin E is new patron
number 37 Mitch Hall is new patron
number 38 Shane Simpson is new patron
number 39
Jennifer bun is new patron number 40 and
I think that's everybody yes okay I'm
I'm very very much caught up there thank
you
really appreciate that support OPI see a
bunch of people asking what's the most
people I've ever had on a stream I think
it's about twelve to thirteen thousand
across all of our platforms so we stream
live on Twitter twitch YouTube and
Facebook so like right now we've got
sixty four hundred on YouTube
twelve hundred on twitch so that's
seventy six hundred we've got close to
another that call it eight hundred on
Facebook so that's like eighty four
hundred and then on Twitter we really
don't get a big streaming audience on
Twitter so we've got our eighty four
hundred and a hundred on Twitter so
eighty five hundred I believe that the
best we've ever done like at peak stream
is twelve or thirteen thousand something
something like that yeah and it's
possible that it's more and I just
didn't quite notice I could have been
very much wrapped up in watching the
propaganda there's dr. Burks she sat
there for twenty minutes yesterday just
waiting for Trump which was truly wacky
I mean it's it's not is it is it a good
use of dr. Burks this time to sit out
there for 20 minutes while Trump is
doing who knows why it's so
disrespectful to the journalists to the
doctors to everybody - everybody quite
frankly uh Nick Nichelle Rose says do
you think these TVs mean Trump will be
doubling down on the campaign style ads
yes my instinct is that the presence of
the TVs is ominous and dystopian we'll
see if I end up being right
Dominic Richardson says all are all
post-world War two presidents war
criminals will listen every post World
War two president has made decisions
that have led to deaths that were not
necessary deaths now necessary is a very
particular narrowly defined word but
through foreign policy and even domestic
policy the decisions presidents make
invariably lead to death even outside of
things like let's drone this guy that is
that is a that is an empirical reality
and
that is a pretty ugly reality to be
perfectly frank let me say thanks to
lightning grin for subscribing with
twitch Prime today Chris R says do you
think we will go back to normal
activities such as bars and restaurants
by 2022
yeah by 2022 I believe so I couldn't
tell you whether it's going to be in two
months or in twelve months but listen if
we're not back to it by 2022 I'm gonna
have bigger problems on my hands let me
put it that way
Harry Bergman has grabbed the YouTube
subscriptions soul says both candidates
have now been accused of sexual assault
this is just so blank up and enraging
Ken H says the model is inaccurate is
the model inaccurate because it was
picked by Trump or is the reason Trump
picked the model because it was
inaccurate
I don't think Trump has much to do with
dr. Burks looking at the IH Emmy model I
think a lot of these decisions are
relatively disaggregated from Trump
quirk equipt says you do not need to
bleach your hair just get a vidal
sassoon in blond color my hair in my
picture was achieved in that manner
that's interesting so there was a
there's a picture on my Instagram and
actually maybe people who know about
hair could tell me about this so I'm
David Pakman on Instagram my third
oldest post somebody photoshopped my
hair onto a Vidal Sassoon box and the
box is called vs Pro Series Ultra
vibrant color I don't know a damn thing
about bleaching hair I said that if we
got to 4,000 patrons we are now at 1890
so we're more than we're almost halfway
there
I said that if we got to 4,000 patrons I
would consider just continuing to let my
hair grow and then bleaching it the same
color as Trump's if I don't have to
bleach it because I've told I've been
told that bleaching your hair is not
good for you I would gladly do it but so
what I'm wondering is would the Vidal
Sassoon product that I posted on my
Instagram and you can fights my third
oldest post would that work I was under
the understanding that with my
hair color you've got it you got to
really do something a little stronger a
little a little more powerful for lack
of a better term millennial cooking
corner asks what is with Michigan right
now protesting they want to let it rip
they want to open her up there was a guy
who was crying he wants actually let me
find the video so we've had a lot of
audience roll over
since I played it a video of a guy
crying because he wants manure um here
it is okay let's pull this up check this
out this was in Michigan today mass
rally you can't buy paint you can't
fight a law you can't pay lawn
fertilizer or grass seed or whatever
come on all statewide really you know
it's time for our seat to be opened up
we're tired of not being able to buy the
things that we need go to look at her
roots okay anyway like dude hardware
stores are open they'll bring it out to
your car Amazon is delivering just place
an order and wait for it be patient
we're all doing it I ordered some books
last week with Prime and I was told may
2nd is when they're gonna get delivered
because of the demand on Amazon
can you imagine crying over over grass
seed right like it's essentially what
the guys doing very weird very very
weird stuff going on there b-boy Chi
says can you add to bingo when
Republicans make an argument for
socialism oh okay
I am playing bingo today so I didn't do
this for a little while because I I
don't want to do the same thing every
stream I'm going to paste the link I'm
pasting it right now in twitch and then
I'm pasting it right now in YouTube you
can generate your own bingo card it'll
randomize the location see you can
generate card it'll mix them all around
this is Trump briefing bingo and if
you've not been on any of my streams so
far by all means oh whoa we're starting
here we go Oh let me switch the c-span
it's a better it's a better feed over on
c-span
it's just delayed 15 seconds don't worry
we're gonna be just fine
Wow why hasn't c-span picked it up
that's really weird all right we'll go
back to the Fox only working on my dead
new cases are declining throughout the
New York metropolitan area cases in the
Detroit and Denver metro areas are flat
Washington d.c Baltimore Philadelphia
and st. Louis are showing great signs of
progress and new cases in Houston and
New Orleans are declining record death
the battle continues but the data
suggests that nationwide we have passed
the peak on new cases unclear hopefully
that will continue and we will continue
to make great progress
these encouraging developments have put
us in a very strong position to finalize
now Fox has gone full Fox feet so now
we'll come to see signs of progress and
new cases in Houston and New Orleans are
declining the battle continues but the
data suggests that nationwide we have
passed the peak on new cases hopefully
that will continue and we will continue
to make great progress
these encouraging developments have put
us in a very strong position to finalize
guidelines for states on reopening the
country which we'll be announcing we're
going to be talking about that tomorrow
we'll be having a news conference
tomorrow sometime during the afternoon
we're going to be announcing guidelines
all right and we'll be talking about
various states and it's very exciting
it's been a horrible time to see such
death and destruction especially when
you come out of what was the greatest
economy in the history of the world the
greatest we've there's never been an
economy like what we had produced but
we'll produce it again and I think we'll
produce it again very fast the medical
and healthcare advances we've made are
critical to our continued progress we've
rapidly developed the most expansive an
accurate testing system anywhere in the
world and have completed more than 3.3
million tests to date we have authorized
48 separate coronavirus tests and the
da is working with 300 companies and
labs to widen our capacity still further
today Abbott Labs announced that it has
developed an antibody test that will
determine if someone has been previously
infected with the corona virus and
potentially developed immunity it's a
great test the company says these tests
could be available to screen up to 20
million people in a matter of weeks my
administration is also distributing vast
amounts of medical supplies to states
across the country through project air
bridge which has been an amazing success
oh now we have completed 44 flights and
these are flights of very very large
airplanes massive cargo planes 44
flights of critical supplies as of today
and an additional 56 flights scheduled
in the near future we have some very
brilliant people working on this it's
logistically incredible what they've
done and we've also been working on this
with the military and these people have
been the genius of all of them together
has been incredible to watch in total
through all channels the federal
government has developed and delivered
39 point four million n95 masks 431
million gloves 57 million surgical masks
and ten point two million gowns we
ordered 500 million masks and they'll be
coming shortly and we've distributed 100
million masks following our use of the
defense production act GM announced that
its first ventilator has come off the
assembly line in Kokomo Indiana a great
place they did it in 11 days from start
to finish a remarkable testament to the
ingenuity of the American worker GM will
ship over 600 ventilators this month
alone with thousands more to come and we
have other companies doing something
similar and I think they said that
there's a brief clip that we have of
General Motors sent to us by General
Motors and I think they might be
wanting to play that for your benefit
please for your benefit
[Music]
right great commercial I know you get a
little bit nervous when you saw there
was a clip about ready to be played but
that was sent to us by General Motors
and we thought it would be a good one to
play it's amazing it's you know what
they've done in a very very short period
of time they're now making thousands of
ventilators and they're coming out of
the factory very rapidly at a clip that
nobody can even believe but we have
others also doing it and these are very
high-grade ventilators so we're helping
a lot of people and at this moment
nobody needs them we have to remember
during the surge nobody's needed in four
weeks now but we'll have them for
stockpiles and very importantly we're
going to have them for other countries
because nobody is able to do things like
we can do and we're going to be able to
help other countries that are having
tremendous problems to put it mildly
my administration is using every
available authority to accelerate the
development study and delivery of
therapies so important therapies
treatments and ultimately what we want
to come up with is a safe vaccine but
frankly the therapies to me are the most
important because it takes care of
people right now the vaccines have to be
tested so it takes a longer period of
time but we have some great potential
therapies already and we'll see how
they're working we'll be able to report
on that I think over the next week or
two tremendous progress has been made at
least 35 clinical trials of promising
therapies are now he studies that
chloroquine bad Pia's companies if you
look at aids if you look at a bola if
you look at so many things they've come
up with the answers to so many things
you wouldn't have believed it and we're
very honored to be working with them
they include antivirals and also in the
something which is incredible keeps the
virus from multiplying a mechanism that
keeps the virus from multiplying immune
therapies that prevent the immune system
from overreaching to the virus and
convalescent plasma treatments that use
antibodies from the blood of recovered
patients that we have a lot of patients
who
recover and they're so happy to have
recovered that the first thing they do
is say we want to give our blood and
they do that it's incredible we have
thousands of people that are doing that
they recover they feel they have an
obligation because they've gotten such
great care right and a lot of them
didn't think they were gonna make it as
the entire US government works to combat
the global pandemic it is absolutely
essential that the key positions at
relevant federal agencies are fully
staffed and we're not allowing that to
take place through our Congress they're
just not they're just not giving it to
us we have many many positions that are
unstaffed because we can't get the
approvals the Democrats are holding us
up we cannot get approval oh god we've
gotten judges because we go through the
process I guess we're up to 448 federal
judges a huge reason why hand that we've
gotten because we focus on it we take
the maximum time because no matter who
the judge is they take vast numbers of
days and hours till probin leaves no
time left for others very unfair system
if a judge is going to be approved in
one hour in one session it doesn't
matter they'll take the maximum number
of hours and days you're talking about
days to get one judge approved oh and
we're close to 250 judges but because of
the way they're doing it there's no time
for anybody else and many of these
people have been waiting for two and a
half years we have a couple that have
been waiting for longer than that
there are currently one hundred and
twenty nine nominees stuck in the Senate
because of partisan obstruction oh come
on
many are nominated for vacancies that
must be filled to assist with the
coronavirus crisis and the resulting
economic challenges and I've read over
the couple of years well I didn't fill
positions I don't fill positions in some
cases we don't need the position and I'm
all for that but in many cases you do
but we can't get them approved by the
Democrats they won't release them the
positions include the Director of
National Intelligence two members of the
Federal Reserve Board of Governors the
assistants
critera treasure note that like with the
DNI he suggested someone completely
unqualified and it imploded like that's
not the fault of Democrats before
administering food security programs and
sonny perdue who's going to be speaking
today saying please can i have this man
can I have this particular person
approved as soon as possible Trump's
hair doesn't does look gray all of a
sudden yeah longtime and the Democrats
won't allow it to happen again
every single judge every nominee we have
goes through maximum
or at least they go through a long
process so it takes days and days and
there's no time left and it's just a
concerted effort to make life difficult
an example is Michael pack
he's my nominee for the CEO of the
broadcasting broadcasting Board of
Governors and he's been stuck in
committee for two years preventing us
from managing the voice of America very
important and have you heard what's
coming out of the voice of America it's
disgusting with things they say are
disgusting toward our country and
Michael pack would get any do a great
job but he's been waiting now for two
years
can't get him approved the Senate has
left Washington until at least May
fourth the Constitution provides a
mechanism for the president to fill
positions in such circumstances the
recess appointment it's called right the
Senate's practice of gaveling into
so-called pro forma sessions where no
one is even there has prevented me from
using the constitutional authority that
we're giving that we're given under the
recessed provisions the Senate should
either fulfill its duty and vote on my
nominees or it should formally adjourn
so that I can make recess appointments
we have a tremendous number of people
that have to come into government and
now more so than ever before because of
the virus and the problem we have to do
it and we have to do whatever we have to
do
they've made it very very difficult to
run government I don't think any
administration has done anywhere near
what we've done in three and a half
years but every block every week they
put up roadblocks whether it's Russia
Russia Russia well whether it's
impeachment hoax oh boy
or whatever it may be it's always
roadblocks and a waste of time if the
house will not agree to that adjournment
I will exercise my constitutional
authority Oh to adjourn both chambers of
Congress the current practice of leaving
town while conducting phony pro forma
sessions is a dereliction of duty not
gonna be of the American people cannot
afford during this crisis it is a scam
what they do it's a scam and everybody
knows it and it's been that way for a
long time and perhaps it's never done
before it's never been done before
nobody's even sure if it has but we're
going to do it we need these people here
we need people for this crisis and we
don't want to play any more political
games I've been waiting for two and a
half years three years to some of these
people and they're great people they
left law firms they left jobs they gave
up everything to do it and they've been
waiting for three years two and a half
years two years one year to get approved
it's ridiculous and everyone knows
they're going to be approved
Trump's on fire but there's only so many
hours in the day when you go through
judges and you go through lengthy
hearings on judges that they know should
be approved immediately and they could
do it in one session one and they could
do it in one hour and instead it takes
so many days in order to advance the
health and security of our nation and
all nations as we announced yesterday
the US government has put a hold on
funding to the WHL World Health
Organization pending a review of the
organization's coverup and mismanagement
of the corona virus outbreak over the
objections of the WHL we took decisive
action and early life-saving action
to suspend travel from China they didn't
want to do it they were angry that we
did it it was early on they were angry
that we did it took him a long time to
realize what was going but I have a
feeling they do exactly what was going
on tragically other nations put their
trust in the w-h-o and they didn't do
any form of ban and you see what
happened to Italy you see what happened
to Spain you see what happened to France
WH shows guidance had failed to control
their borders at a very crucial phase
quickly unleashing the contagion around
the world that was a horrible tragic
mistake or perhaps they knew I'm sure
they didn't know the gravity of it but
perhaps they knew because if they knew
the gravity that would be an even worse
offense to ease the economic pain of
millions of American families we've now
processed 300 billion dollars in loans
to more than 1 million small businesses
through the paycheck protection program
this action has saved millions of
American jobs it's been an incredible
success and they want to replenish it
now but again the Democrats don't want
to do that this is money that goes to
the workers of our country phase one was
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
and now phase two we want to do two
hundred and fifty billion this goes to
workers right and it goes to small
businesses so we can save all the small
businesses around our nation Mike
McFarland from Nebraska recently said
this historic relief has been a godsend
for his small factory and the 136
Americans who work there save those jobs
another small business owner Tim Miller
from Oklahoma called the program a total
lifesaver fors auto repair shops for
employees stories like these underscore
why Congress must replenish released
sounds the Paycheck protection program
immediately the Republicans want to do
it they want to do it immediately they
want to do it now and the Democrats are
stopping it a short
I'm ago CDC issued public health
guidelines for critical industries in a
few moments agricultural secretary sonny
Perdue will elaborate on how these
guidelines apply to our nation's
dedicated workers in the food processing
profession because it's a profession
it's incredible what they do food
processing and they're keeping our
grocery stories full the shelves are not
bare like the shelves that I inherited
when we took over the stockpile the
medical stockpile where the shelves were
bare the cupboard was bare I say
tomorrow I'll also be leading a call
with elected officials who will consult
with my administration as we work to
restore our economy to full speed and we
really think with all of the stimulus
and all of the pent-up demand we're
going to have an economy that really
comes back quickly and would like to see
it more than match what we had before
what we had before was a miracle and we
think this is going to be even more than
a miracle we're going to do it because
we have the greatest people in the world
we'll also be speaking to America's
governors tomorrow and then we'll be
announcing exactly what's happening you
already know we'll be opening up states
some states much sooner than others and
we think some of the states can actually
open up before the deadline of May 1st
that'll be a train wreck and I think
that that will be a very exciting time
indeed governors are looking for that
chomping at the bit to get going again
not all states are the same they're very
different some are having very little
problems some have done such a good job
that they have very little problem and
they're ready to go so vice president
Pence and I will be speaking with the
governors tomorrow we'll be discussing
procedures today I spoke with the
leaders of many of our nation's most
renowned companies and organizations on
how to achieve the full resurgence of
the American economy
my discussions included top leaders in
health and health care transportation
technology financial services food
beverages hospitality
real-estate retail agriculture
construction energy labor manufacturing
and sports industries we want to get a
country open again we want to have our
sports leagues open you'll want to watch
sports it's important we miss sports we
miss everything we want to get back
these experts and innovators provided
extremely productive feedback on how to
safely reboot our economy they gave us a
lot of great ideas we spoke to a lot of
very very smart people the highest of
the high tech the level of IQ and some
of those calls was about the highest
you've ever seen heard a phone call that
I can tell you but we have a lot of
great thought went into those calls and
a lot of questions came out and also
statements very strong statements as to
what they recommend it was I think it
was a great day we did a lot of a lot of
calling with a lot of very prominent
people but more importantly very smart
people and people that loved our country
they talked about the vital importance
of our wide array of relief measures to
address the present crisis and they
provided valuable insights on how to
move forward including on the role of
protective gear
where we have tremendous amounts of
protective gear coming in robust testing
and the future use of therapies and
treatments they also underscored the
crucial importance of strong supply
chains and communications infrastructure
we're talking about infrastructure for
the middle of our country talking about
broadband and things that they frankly
don't have and haven't had for a long
time because a lot of politicians forgot
about them
can't forget about them they're really
the heart and soul can't forget about
them and we're talking about the
telemedical it's a new thing and it's
incredible what they've been able to do
this is an industry that's just growing
but it's take it's grown by leaps and
bounds over the last five weeks people
are learning so much without the ability
to see a doctor they're learning so much
and a lot of good things are happening
that's something that's really going
forward I think going to
very important for our country as we've
seen throughout our proud history
America is never greater than when our
people are working in unison toward a
common goal that's what's happening
right now we'll go ahead we'll forge an
even brighter future today than we had
and we'll be along with other nations
hopefully we'll working with other
nations will be the comeback kids all of
us all of us it's incredible what's
going on I'm very proud of the people of
this country I'm very proud of the
people I spoke to today these are truly
great brilliant people and we've gained
tremendous insight so tomorrow is going
to be a very big day we're going to be
speaking with the governor's we'll have
some information on some openings and
again we'll have some openings that will
be will exceed our expectations and
they'll be safe they'll be strong but we
want to get our country back we want to
get our country back and we're going to
do it and we're going to do it soon with
that I'd like to ask dr. Burks to come
up and say a few words and then
secretary sonny perdue and then vice
president pence thank you very much
thank you what a mess thank you
Thank You mr. president
and thank you for summarizing on the
States and what we're seeing so over the
last five to six days we've seen
declines in cases across the country and
this has been very in reassuring for us
at the same time we know that mortality
and the fatalities that we're facing
across the United States continue we
know the number of people who are still
in the hospitals in the ICUs and we want
to continue to recognize the health care
workers who are on the front lines and
really recognize how low the United
States case fatality rates are compared
to other countries and this is really
due not only to our technology but how
that technology is utilized to save
lives at the same time I'm inspired by
the American people who continue social
distancing these cases continue to
decline because of the strong work of
the American people I also wanted to let
you know that we do have nine states
that have less than a thousand cases in
less than 30 new cases per day so we're
looking at States and metro areas as
individual individual areas we talked
before how each of these curves are
different each of the cases experiences
are different we have some states like
California and Washington State Oregon
that never really had a peak because of
so much work that their populations did
to decrease and keep the new cases down
so each of these into individual states
and individual metros are being studied
very specifically I do want to highlight
and we are remaining concerned and we've
been having discussions with Rhode
Island Rhode Island and Providence are
in a unique situation first they had
increasing cases from the New York City
area and now they have new increase in
cases from the Boston area they're
caught between two incredible hotspots
in the country they're doing an
extraordinary job they're caring for the
individuals in the front lines but
Providence continues to have new cases
and we do continue to work with specific
states that have specific outbreaks
related to individual occurrences I will
just remind the American people again
this is a highly contagious virus social
gatherings coming together is there
always a chance that a a symptomatic
person can spread the virus unknowingly
no one is intending to spread the virus
we know if you are sick you will stay
home but to all of you that are out
there that would like to join together
and just have that dinner party for 20
don't do it yet continue to follow the
presidential guidelines we really
appreciate the work of the American
people we see as a country we're
improving we see as metro areas we're
improving we see as communities as
counties and as states were improving
but that also still requires everyone to
continue to social distance and in the
end we do have states that have very few
cases and very few new cases and so
these are the ones a president is
referring to that have been silent
relatively silent throughout this
epidemic and pandemic that many of us
have faced and so these are the groups
are working in with very specifically
and each of these governors and each of
these mayors will have to make decisions
after generalized guidelines are put out
so that they can do what's best for
their communities they are at the
frontline and I wanted to conclude by
really thanking my PEPFAR teams around
the world who have been working
tirelessly throughout the world to
ensure that Africa and Asia doesn't
experience this level of infections that
we have seen here they've turned over
their capacities from their embassies
our US hires throughout the world our
ambassadors are still on the frontline
with our local staff working with
ministries of how to confront this virus
around the globe and I assure you that
they are continuing to invest in the
health structures the laboratory and the
frontline care to ensure that all of the
work that we have done against TB HIV
and malaria
continues but that we use our capacity
our laboratories our clinics our
hospitals that have been built by the
American people and the generosity of
the American people to really combat
this kovat 19 around the globe thank you
so we can play figure out which states
those nine all right Thank You mr.
president for the opportunity to be here
with you today and do I want you to know
it's an honor to represent you and
leading the Department of Agriculture
and represent the constituency who are
crucial in maintaining our nation's food
security we're saving us to keep food on
the table of our American families not
only just food but wholesome and safe
food as well I'd like to start my
remarks today by echoing what my
colleagues the CDC have been saying
regarding the health and safety of our
central employees across the United
States
CDC's provided strategies there that
aimed at helping our most critical
workers both in health care and in food
processing to quickly and safely to
return to work after potential exposure
the Cova 19 provided those workers our
symptom free and this guidance will help
these critical industries in the food
sector provide to protect the health and
safety of essential workers while
keeping critical functions working
throughout the Cova 19 response as we
know any employee who develops symptoms
while on the job should go home
immediately and the interim guidance is
in line with CDC's recommendations for
health care workers caring for those
sick with kovin 19 so we appreciate the
dedication and commitment of all the
brave men and working women working to
keep their communities fed and we will
continue to work with the CDC to keep
those individuals as safe as possible
during these challenging times in that
vein there's been a lot happening this
week it's Cova 19 is impacting food
processing for some of these as you know
for Americans who be may be worried
about access to good food because of
this I want to assure you the American
food supply is strong resilient and safe
and in fact our food supply chain is
shown
tremendous agility in shifting
production and logistics so suddenly
from restaurant and institutional
settings to retail settings to all the
employers out there in this sector it's
critical that you follow CDC guidelines
and guidance and best practices to keep
all of your employees and people safe
and healthy to employers and local
public health officials advising them
the CDC has issued guidelines on how to
mitigate a situation if you have a
positive case in one of your facilities
we need our local health authorities and
our state health authorities to do
everything they can to balance the
demand of keeping our facilities
operational and our critical industries
going at the same time keeping the
health and safety of employees is a top
priority as well as our communities so I
want to also take this time to thank all
of our critical essential food supply
chain workers the entire country is
counting on these patriotic individuals
by doing the work in our food supply
chain these dedicated workers include
obviously farmers and producers but also
processors truckers and grocery store
workers as you know America is depending
on what you have the food we need to
feed our families and you're the ones
who are making that happen thank you as
an entire nation we're truly thankful
for the work you're doing and we
recognize that you are the true
patriotic heroes during this national
emergency along with our health care
workers so before I sign off here mr.
president I want to remind you and all
of us have one more thing in the United
States we have plenty of food for all of
our citizens I want to be clear the bear
store shelves that you may see in some
cities in the country
are a demand issue not a supply and yet
people athiest prepared and packaged to
be sold in a restaurant or a school is
significantly different than the way
it's packaged for you to buy in the
grocery store our supply chain is
sophisticated efficient integrated and
synchronized and it's taken us a few
days to relocate the misalignment
between institutional settings and
grocery settings but that does not mean
that we don't have enough food
in this country to feed the American
people you might think of it as an
interstate when it's ruled flowing along
well and you have a crash at one place
it backs up and that's what's happened
in the food supply chain but we're
working through that you know all this
through all this our food supply chain
is proven to be very resilient just like
American people the extent we have
challenges we have and continue to need
to work through it all together and we
can and we will get through this with a
whole of American approach mr. president
and the critical partnership between
state and local health officials a
management of companies and the
employees and we will meet any
challenges we face by working together
thank you sir for the opportunity all
right dude before the vice president
comes up I just wanted to say speaking
of Sonny China has paid us billions of
dollars many many billions of dollars in
tariffs with the lie we pay that we've
distributed some to the farmers because
they were targeted we have many billions
of dollars being held by Sonny and I've
told him to distribute much of that
money to the farmers our farmers were
targeted and now they're benefiting by
the amount that they were targeted and
we are very honored to do that and Sonny
you're going to start that process very
soon you let the farmers know nobody can
take advantage of our farmers so
wouldn't you I guess we have a lot of
money that we've taken in from China
we're going to be distributing that
money how does he not come we pay to
Tara from Sonny to the farmers and is
tremendous money over and above that
that money was paid directly into the
Treasury of the United States this has
never happened to China before they
never gave us ten cents now they're
paying us billions of dollars that we
appreciate it so thank you very much on
a great job please Mike please
godnot pence Thank You mr. president the
White House coronavirus task force met
today was reported to us that we've
conducted and completed three million
three hundred twenty four thousand tests
across the nation more than six hundred
nineteen thousand Americans have tested
positive but as you reflected yesterday
when we welcomed
coronavirus survivors here to the White
House from across the country some more
than 45,000 Americans have fully
recovered sadly we mourn the loss of
more than 27 thousand of our our
countrymen our hearts are with their
families and with the families of all of
those that continue to struggle with the
serious consequences of this illness
but as dr. Burks just reflected despite
the heartbreaking losses we're getting
there America because of the efforts of
people all across this country to put
into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines because of their
adherence to the direction of state and
local authorities as dr. Burks just
reflected we we see great signs of
progress from the west coast to the east
coast
president Trump has directed our team to
develop new guidelines that will be
presented tomorrow to our nation's
governors and and released to the
American people thereafter the American
people will be encouraged to know that
as we stand here today 24 percent of the
counties of this country have no
reported coronavirus cases in fact half
of the states in America have less than
2,500 cases per state this is a great
tribute to the efforts by the people of
those communities but as the president
suggested when we unveil the guidelines
that the team has been working to
present tomorrow to our nation's
governors we're going to reflect on the
fact that as the president said there
will be areas of the country the
will require continued mitigation and
strong efforts and there will be other
areas of the country that will be be
given guidance for greater flexibility
the president is so directed our team
when we think of more than six hundred
and nineteen thousand Americans having
tested positive more than 45,000 having
recovered we wanted to announce today
that the FDA recently announced efforts
to facilitate the development and access
to convalescent plasma mr. president
you've spoken about this people who have
recovered from the corona virus have
antibodies in your bloodstream that can
attack the virus the Mayo Clinic today
is working with the Red Cross to make
sure that coronavirus patients have
access to the convalescent plasma
treatments and over a thousand
institutions across America have already
joined this program and we want to urge
every American who has recovered from
the corona virus for at least two and
preferably four weeks to contact your
local blood or plasma donation center
and arrange to donate it's one more way
that the American people can do their
part and step forward and thousands have
already done so when we know that tens
of thousands will join them on the
subject of supplies mr. president I'll
be very brief because you retail the
great amount as the president mentioned
the air bridge is completed forty four
flights 56 more are scheduled but on the
subject of facial masks which are so
important for the protection of critical
infrastructure pleased to report that
the average daily delivery through the
commercial network through our air
bridge is 22 million facial masks coming
into the marketplace the average
inventory in the network over a seven
day period is 80 million masks and FEMA
is actually working as we speak to move
facial masks to priority infrastructure
food supply first responders there'll be
six point five million masks that go out
before the end of this week an
additional 20 million before April the
20th and then we'll be adding six point
five million each
every week at the president's direction
we're going to ensure that all of those
that work in food supply all of those
first responders have access to masks
and we're increasing those every day
finally I know I speak for the president
when I say how proud we are of all of
our health care workers across the
country and how proud we are of the men
and women in uniform our medical
professionals who have been deployed
across the nation literally by the
thousands in fact as we stand here today
576 doctors nurses and other military
medical professionals have been deployed
to 13 hospitals across the nation 10 in
New York and one in Connecticut Texas in
Louisiana each and as the president
reflected a few days ago because we did
not have the happily did not have the
demand on the Javits Center and on the
Comfort in New York City at the
president's direction we have deployed
doctors and nurses from those two
facilities two hospitals in fact the
president and I were just speaking to
Mayor DeBlasio just before we came out
and he expressed his great admiration
and appreciation for the relief that
these medical military personnel have
provided two incredibly dedicated people
in our hospitals 258 medical personnel
just yesterday were deployed off the
ship and out of the Javits Center into
New York with that mr. president I'll
step aside but it's remarkable to think
of all that we've accomplished over the
last month since you first issued the
presidential guidelines for America Wow
the truth is because of what the
American people have done over the last
30 days we are slowing the spread we are
ensuring that every American family to
have access to the health care that we
want any member of our family to have
with the greatest health care
professionals in the world we're saving
lives and we're healing our land and so
we want to thank the American people for
all you have done and tomorrow we'll be
presenting a new guidance to the
governors of this country about how we
build on our progress and reopen America
in a safe and responsible way Thank You
mr. president
thanks Mike
recess appointment mr. president I could
see very simple if they don't act on
getting these people approved that we
need because of the we need them anyway
but we especially need now because of
the pandemic we are going to do
something that will be something I'd
prefer not doing but which I should do
and I will do if I have to Caitlin go
ahead
before the countries where they feel cut
real reopening their stores their
restroom but not isn't that what health
officials it's what I want to do we have
great tests and we want the states to
administer these tests for the most part
but we're standing behind them we have
great tests we've done more testing now
than any country as you know not pretty
the world by far we have the best tests
of any country in the world nobody has
the quality of tests the if you look at
Abbott what they've come up with in a
short period of time they've been
incredible Roche has been incredible we
have the best tests in the world and we
will be working very much with the
governors of the states we want them to
do it we're not going to be running a
parking lot in Arkansas we're not going
to be running a parking lot where you
have a Walmart which has been great by
the way Walmart has done a fantastic job
but where you have a testing center and
running that from Washington DC the
states are much better equipped to do it
but we'll be working with the states
we're standing behind the states we're
going to work very closely with the
governors in terms of that getting
additional equipment it used to be three
four weeks ago two weeks ago could we
get more ventilators more ventilators
right and we got on ventilators and you
don't hear that anymore so he's not
pretty amazing what we've been able to
do yeah go ahead John
can they get a bike on her widespread
enough to wear
well I think the companies will
determine that and the governor's will
determine that and the federal
government and if we're not happy we'll
take very strong action against a state
or a governor if we're not happy with
the job of governor's doing we'll let
them know about it and as you know we
have very strong action we can take
including the closed-down but we don't
want to do that we're working with the
governor's that we're working closely
with the governor's the relationship has
been very good vice president has had a
lot of conversations over the last two
weeks with either 50 or almost 50
governor's on every conversation and
they've been really positive
conversations we have the right to do
whatever we want but we wouldn't do that
but no we would have the right to close
down what they're doing wrong if we want
to do that but we don't want to do that
and I don't think there'll be any reason
to do that but we have the right to do
that Steve well I don't know too much
about it but I understand my name is
there what a lot I don't know where
they're going how they're going I do
understand it's not delaying anything
what and I'm satisfied with that I don't
I don't imagine it's a big jump sure
people will be very happy to get a big
fat beautiful check and my name is on it
yeah go ahead please go ahead please
dr. parks just set the bird island
you're seeing an increase in cases from
people that are coming from Boston in
New York you just said you'd like to
reopen some states before May 1 how will
you stop at second spike in cases of
people with travelling between states
how we control the flow of people well
the governor's can control that flow as
an example in fact I just saw a little
while ago was reporters if he tells
States to open they have to open
controlling the flow in infectious oh
that's up to the governor's listen
states rights they gotta figure it out
read that about Rhode Island so they
have to watch it they have to be very
careful yeah please president you said
along with other nations what form would
it take are you considering also are
relaxing the border between Canada and
the US so our relationship with Canada
is very good we'll talk about that it
will be one of the early borders to be
released Canada's doing well we're doing
well we'll see but at some point we'll
be doing that in the meantime nations
that are heavily infected we have a lot
of nations that are heavily infected
some are getting better some are still
on the way up unfortunately and we're
keeping very strong borders with those
nations but with Canada we are talking
about different things yeah please
president you said the evidence suggests
that nationwide we have passed the peak
on new cases what's your evidence for
that what are the numbers well all we're
doing is looking at the numbers we're
looking at our graphs we're looking at
our models we're getting a great
response from Debra and from Tony and
from many of the professionals that are
working we have great professionals
working with us and I think based on
that we're we're doing very well based
on that it looks like we're headed
absolutely in the right direction but
some states are looking at other states
and they're saying I can't imagine what
they're going through because they're
not in that position they're in very
good shape I would say that we have 20
states at least but you really have 29
births that are not really good shape
you have others that are getting much
better and I think with almost a few
exceptions you have every state that is
either doing better or on the way to
doing better yeah please
threat to a adjourn or adjourn Congress
clearly of the power article two section
three but that'd be quite radical to do
earlier last month you were Neoga office
talked about now is not the time for
partisanship how will that act lower the
partisanship in this town and could it
potentially hinder your ability to get
something done on coronavirus it is look
it's been a very partisan government for
a long period of time not just this
administration you can go back into the
last two administrations you've seen a
lot of partisanship and even now you
would think that we wouldn't have as an
example with the paycheck plan that's
going so well it's so smooth so
beautiful almost without a hitch all of
that money is being distributed to small
businesses they're giving it to their
employees it's keeping them ready viable
so when we open and now it's been so
good that it's almost depleted and we
want to replenish it and we can't get
the Democrats to approve it and that's a
program that they and everybody else
admit that are great so you do have
partisanship total distortion we have
been trying for years to get people
approved for positions people have left
one man left a law firm when he opened
the whole thing by just slamming various
Democrats second if he left it was two
years ago we have people that have been
waiting for three years and we can't get
them approved by the Democrats in the
Senate because they're taking so long to
approve our judges now I have to tell
you that I'm totally in favor of what
rich is doing with judges because it's
always seems to be a priority course and
it's a very important priority I think
it's one of the great trademarks of this
administration we've approved record
numbers of federal judges and appellate
judges and two Supreme Court judges why
he's got to be run rather than approving
somebody who's highly qualified somebody
that everybody knows is going to be
approved rather than going quickly they
take the maximum amount of time whatever
that time may be and what they're doing
by doing that is taking days question
was about partisanship and Trump's
bashing Dems people that get phenomenal
reviews
mitii are going maximum number of hours
and what they do is there's only so many
hours of the day now we could have said
let's stay I would have been in favor of
that they didn't choose to do it but I
have a very strong power I'd rather not
use that power but we have way over a
hundred people that we very badly need
in this administration that should have
been approved a long time ago and one of
them is the head of Voice of America if
you look at what they're doing basically
what they're saying about our country
it's a disgrace the people that are
running that we have somebody that's
really good really talented and that
loves our country and I want to get
these people approved that's one of many
we have professionals Sonny you've been
waiting for how long have you been
waiting for the man that we're talking
about coming in two and a half years so
sonny perdue just happens to be here
talking about something else already
forgot one of the most important
positions as Secretary of Agriculture is
the position its distribution we need it
now we're talking about shelves were
talking about cupboards
he needs it he's been waiting he didn't
know he's going to get this question
you've been waiting 2 and 1/2 years the
person is exceptional that person left a
very good job and it's embarrassing to
me he'll say do you think you'll get
that man approved he's been saying that
to me for a long time it's because of
the Democrats and what we're doing is
and I think anybody here would do it
judges are a priority a federal judge is
going to sit for 50 years potentially
young judge got to be sitting for that's
always going to have to be a priority
but because they're taking so much time
and approving every they're trying to
put us through the mill that's when you
talk about partisanship and it's never
ever happened before you can look at
every administration of the history of
this country nobody nobody has ever had
hundreds of people not approved after
three and a half years go ahead place a
timeline for that though if if Congress
doesn't belong there you know they've
been warned and they've been warned
right now if they don't approve it then
we're gonna go this route right we'll
probably be challenged and
and we'll see who wins but when the
court hears that we aren't getting
people approved as Sonny would say for
two and a half years for an important
position that we need because of this
crisis we needed these people before but
now we really need these people back to
the numbers for a second when you talk
about the numbers
the jobless claims are gonna come out
tomorrow it's likely around five million
more Americans putting their names in
front employment benefits but yet there
are still a couple thousand people as
well dying a day because of coronavirus
when you talk about opening up the
American economy or at least in parts
now how do you balance that decision out
given good question I'm never gonna get
an answer well we are there has to be a
balance you know there's also death
involved in keeping it close and I've
gone over this with you and I believe
this so strongly when you look at mental
health when you look at suicides suicide
hotlines who which are exploding people
losing their job explode you look at
drugs and people that didn't take drugs
and now they're becoming drug addicted
because they're going through a problem
they have no job they have no money
coming in other than the money we're
getting them we've opened up the large
extent we're helping people this is why
I wish the Democrats would help us a
little bit with it because they should
it's purely partisan what they're doing
and it's bad for our country but but you
know there is death by doing by having
this strongly closed country we have to
get back to work with all of that being
said we're going to start with States
and with governors that have done a
great job and they're gonna open it up
as they see fit and we're going to be
right behind them and we're going to be
working we're gonna be supplying them
with things if they don't have them we
want them to have them we're gonna be
helping them with ventilators after this
is over something answered they can't
say oh the federal government we want
them to have they've had a lot of
options many of the governors have had a
lot of options rather over the years to
buy ventilators they didn't choose to do
it so we're going to be helping them to
fill up their stockpiles we're going to
have plenty and as I said I'm very proud
to do it we're going to be helping other
nations we're going to be helping Italy
Spain France other nations and we're
going to be helping them strongly I
the Grusha is going to need ventilators
having a hard time in Moscow we're gonna
help them we're gonna help other
countries that need ventilators we're
going to have a lot you see it with
General Motors you see it with other
companies that are producing we're going
to have hundreds of thousands of
ventilators and it's a great thing to
have yes in the batteries
is anybody freezing you know it's very
cold out here so we can leave early
right okay couple of go ahead please
[Music]
well you don't know what you have do you
think you're getting honest numbers from
some of these countries do you really
believe those numbers in this vast
country called China and that they have
a certain number of cases and a certain
number that does anybody really believe
that here's a story we report everything
we're reporting the cases and our
reporting is good we're reporting every
death in fact I see this morning where
New York added 3,000 deaths because they
died and they're now saying rather than
it was a heart attack they're saying it
was a heart attack caused by this so
they're adding if you look at it that's
it and everything we have is documented
reported and what they are doing is just
in case they're calling it this and
that's okay that's okay but we are we
have more cases because we do more
reports about that we have more cases
because everything is down because
anybody really believed the numbers of
some of these countries that you've been
watching and you've been reporting on
and then it's like they didn't have the
big thing there have been some really
really bad heavily and really some
countries that are in big big trouble
and they're not reporting the facts
question was about that that's up to
them not kill all I know is we report
the facts and we're a country that's
getting better John go ahead mr.
president multiple sources are telling
Fox News today that the United States
government now has high confidence that
while the coronavirus is a naturally
occurring virus it emanated from a
virology lab in Wuhan that because of
lacks safety protocols and in turn was
involved to hear God later infected her
boyfriend and then went to the wet
market in Wuhan where it began to spread
does that correspond with what you have
heard from well I don't want to say that
John but I will tell you more and more
we're hearing the story and we'll see
when you say multiple sources though
there's a case where you can use the
word sources but we are doing a very
thorough examination of this horrible
situation that happened guide please in
your many conversations with President
Xi mr. president did you ever do
with him State Department concerns about
lack safety protocols that had been
reported to the State Department from
the embassy in Beijing about that
laboratory I don't want to discuss what
I talked to him about the laboratory I
just don't want to discuss it it's
inappropriate right now please go ahead
in the back Australia there have been
calls in our country for our prime
minister Scott Morrison to make funding
for w-h-o conditional on reforms to the
organisation wanted to get your thoughts
on that and if you had any advice for
mr. Morrison look I feel very badly
about the World Health Organisation but
it's been a tool of China it's been as I
say totally China centric you take a
look at everything that's happened
they've been wrong I was all for it at
the beginning what do I know I worked in
I said World Health Organization's isn't
that wonderful and then you start to see
all the mistakes they didn't want us to
close our borders to China to Wuhan
specifically then you want our borders
closed you take a look Mike was there
we're all there and they're criticizing
me for closing the border I did that
very early by the way I did that very
early while Nancy Pelosi was trying to
have in San Francisco parties in
Chinatown because they she thought it
would be great she want to show that
this thing doesn't exist
these are people I tell you we have some
politicians on the other side that don't
know what they're doing if you look at
if you look at timelines you got to look
at some timelines but the world the
World Health Organization just like the
World Trade Organization I'm telling you
I call them they have been treating the
United States for decades so badly and
they've been so in favor of China China
took off when it joined the World Trade
Organization because of what's happened
think of it they consider that way over
to WTO now I based on the question a
developing nation - in my book okay
we're developing - but the fact is we
have been treated so badly by these
organizations and believe me I'm looking
at that one - we're winning a lot of
lawsuits right now that we never won
before in the past we're winning a lot
of money that we never won in the past
that's what the world trade but with the
World Health Organization what's
happened there is a disgrace
here's the other thing we pay 400 to 500
million dollars a year China's paying 38
39 and 40 million dollars a year and
it's like they control this group I
could do that too if I want to devote
full time to order have some very
capable people dealing with that i
tetris okay what I could do it to I
could do very well with that
but there's something going on it's
something going on that's very bad now
the 500 million that we save will
determine we're going to make a
determination over a little period of
time but they're going to either have to
make massive changes I don't even know
if they're going to be able to do that
well we're gonna give money to people we
want to help people you know what we do
in Africa with AIDS people have no idea
what we do and the money we spent we
were talking about it the other day
doctor we are spending billions of
dollars to help people in the case of
one that dr. Burks is very much involved
in AIDS millions of dollars and you know
what it's a great thing nobody talks
about it nobody gives us credit we do
that and we do it very directly dude
what are you doing spending billions of
dollars to help people live and all over
the world but we're spending five
hundred million dollars to the World
Health Organization and it's like a
runaway train where it's making no sense
but he can't stop I'm very much involved
it's been going on for a long period of
time and we don't want to be the suckers
anymore so it's cold out we will talk to
you tomorrow big day tomorrow
very big day so tomorrow we are going to
get some list of countries from Donald
Trump that a list of states rather that
are going to be set to open up that's
tomorrow and it could be the start of a
veritable disaster a second wave before
the first wave even really ends if
you're watching on youtube please
remember to hit the like and subscribe
buttons every single one of you who does
that is so much appreciated TroKar cat
thank you so much for the large generous
super chat I so appreciate it saying
information is
power and I want nothing to do with
Trump's signature so appreciate
everybody's support we'll be back here
tomorrow at roughly the same time for a
list of states that are going to be
letting it rip apparently thanks also to
the 51 people who made a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
really appreciate every single one of
you
you